many videos ago we introduced the idea
of a projection
and in that case we dealt more
particularly with projections onto lines
that went through the origin so if we
had some line let's say l
and let's say l is equal to
the span
of some
vector v or you could say alternately
you could say that l is equal to the set
of all
multiples of v such that the scalar
factors are just any real numbers these
are both representations of lines that
go through the origin we defined a
projection of any vector onto that line
and let me just draw it real fast so let
me see
let me draw some axes so that is my
little straighter than that
if that is my vertical axis and that is
my horizontal axis
just like that and let's say i have some
line that goes through the origin
let's say and that doesn't go to the
origin let's say that that line right
there goes to the origin so that is l
we knew visually that a projection of
some vector l onto l
some vector x onto l so let's say that
that is a vector x
the visually it's essentially your if
you were to draw if you have some light
coming straight down it would be the
shadow of x onto l
so this right here
that right there was the projection
projection onto the line l
of
the vector x and we defined it more
formally we kind of took a perpendicular
we said that x minus the projection of
x onto l is perpendicular to the line l
or perpendicular to everything or
orthogonal to everything on the line l
but this is how at least i visualize
it's kind of the shadow as you go down
onto the line l and this was a special
case in general of projections you might
notice that l is going to be a valid
subspace you could prove it to yourself
it contains the zero vector it goes
through the origin it's closed under
addition any any member of it plus any
other member of it is going to be
another member of it and it's closed
under under scalar multiplication you
could take any member of it and scale it
up or down it's still going to be an l
so this was a subspace when we defined
this and just as a bit of a reminder of
what it was we did we were able to
figure out what this projection is for
some line l if you have some spanning
vector the projection
onto
this line l that goes in through the
origin of the vector x we figured out
was
it was x
dot your spanning vector for your line
so x dot v
over
v dot v which is really just the length
of v squared so all of this was a number
and then you mult and you want it to be
in the same direction as your line it's
going to be another vector in your line
so it's going to be
times
the vector v so it's just going to be a
scaled up or a scaled down version of
your spanning vector maybe your spanning
vector is like that and really any
vector in your line could be a spanning
vector any vector other than the zero
vector
now that was a projection onto a line
which was a special kind of subspace but
now we're going to broaden our
definition of a projection to any
subspace so we already know
that if let's go let's let me draw a
little dividing line to show that we're
doing something slightly different
we already know that if
v is a subspace v is a subspace
subspace
sub space
of rn
then v
complement is also a subspace of rn
so the orthogonal complement of v
also
also a subspace
and let's say we have some members or
let me write it this way then if we have
these two subspaces you have a subspace
and you have its orthogonal complement
we already learned that if you have any
member of rn so let's say that x
is a member of rn
then x can be represented
x can be represented as the sum of a
member of v
and a member of the orthogonal
complement of v where let me write this
where the vector v is a member of the
subspace v
and the vector w is a member of the
orthogonal complement of the subspace v
just like that we saw this several
videos ago we proved that this was true
for any member of rn
now given that we can define
we can define
the projection
the projection of x
onto the subspace v
onto the subspace v as being equal to
just the part of x you can kind of view
it you know these are two orthogonal
parts of x we define the projection onto
v as the part of x that came from v
it's equal to
just that vector v alternately you could
say that the projection
the projection of x
onto the orthogonal complement of sorry
transpose onto the orthogonal complement
of v is going to be equal to
w so this piece right here is a
projection onto the subspace v this
piece right here is a projection onto
the orthogonal complement of the
subspace v now what i want to do in this
video is show you that these two
definitions
that this definition right here when
it's in conjunction with this right here
this is equivalent to what we learned up
here if the subspace v that we're
dealing with if the subspace v that
we're dealing with is a line and you
know because this was a valid subspace
but not all subspaces are going to be
lines and to see this we can revisit an
example that we saw several videos ago
several videos ago
we had this matrix here a this two by
two matrix and then we had this other
vector b that was a member of the column
space of a and we did this matrix we did
this problem to show you that that the
the shortest solution to this right here
was a unique member of the row space
hopefully that gets your your memory on
track for when this this problem when we
first did it but let me graph it and
show you that the solution to that
problem we could have just as easily
taken a projection onto a subspace so
let me graph everything in this problem
this might
help you remember also about the problem
so let me draw my axes just like that so
the first thing we learned you know you
could solve this but i already did this
in a video i think it was two or three
videos ago the null space of a or all of
the x's that satisfy ax is equal to 0 is
a span of the vector 2 3.
so you go 2 to the right
2 and then you go a 3 up
1 2
and so it's the span of this vector
and so the span of that vector is just
all of the all of the points well that
vector specifies that point but if you
scale this vector up and down you're
going to specify all of the points on
this line all the points on that line
let me draw it like that
that's good enough it shouldn't curve
down like that at the end so let me draw
a little straighter so this is the null
space
that is our null space of that matrix
right there and then the row space was a
span of the vector three minus two you
see that right here three minus two is
the first row this guy is just a
multiple of that one that's why we don't
have this guy right here in the span as
well and if we were to graph it three
minus two you go out 3 and then you go
down 1 2
it would be the span of this vector
right there
let me draw it like that and you take
all the scalar multiples of that vector
you're going to specify and you'd put
those vectors in standard position
they're going to specify or their tips
are going to be on points along this
line right there
along that line right there i'm trying
to make sure i draw them orthogonally so
this right here is the row space
that right there is the row space of a
which is the same thing as the column
space of a transpose
and we know that these guys are each
other's orthogonal complements we know
we've seen this in multiple videos that
the null space of a is the orthogonal
complement
of the row space and we also know that
the orthogonal complement of the null
space is equal to the row space
everything in this is orthogonal to
everything in that everything in that is
orthogonal to everything in this and you
could see it here in this graph that
these two spaces which are represented
by these lines that go through the
origin are orthogonal and it makes sense
that any you know we said at really the
beginning of the video that anything in
r 2 in this situation so this is r 2
that r 2 can be represented as some
sum of a unique member of our row space
and a unique member of its orthogonal
complement let's say i have
that point right there what is the what
how could i represent it as a sum of a
member of this and a member of that
well if i go along
this guy i have this vector right here
i have that vector right there
along that line
and then i have this vector right here
this vector right here if i were to
shift it this is it drawn in standard
position but i can draw a vector
wherever i want these lines are just all
of the vectors drawn in standard
position with their tails at the origin
but we learned in really i think the
first or second vector videos that i can
draw them wherever i want so if i add
this vector and that vector i can shift
this vector over and this vector will be
right there
and there you have it i took an
arbitrary point in r2 and i can
represent it as a sum of a member of my
row space and a member of the row
space's orthogonal complement or the
null space
but just to review what we originally
did in that problem is we looked at the
solution set of this we said the
solution set of this looks like this
it's a it has a particular solution plus
members of your null space plus
homogeneous solutions we've seen that
multiple videos ago so 3 0 it looks like
this
plus members of the null space so your
solution set is going to be parallel to
this but shifted to the right by 3. so
it looks let me draw a little neater
than that
and no
let me draw it like
that and then it goes down like the
second part i didn't draw there you go
oh that's not good either maybe i'm
being too picky okay so this is your
solution set
this is your solution
this is your solution set and if you
remember in that video we said hey
there's some member of this solution set
that is also a member of our row space
and that member that it of the solution
said that is a member of our row space
is going to be the shortest solution
and we saw that you could see it
visually right here right this vector
right here
it is in our row space it is a member of
our row space and it also specifies a
point on our solution set and you can
see visually that it's going to be the
shortest solution and one way you could
think about it is this is the projection
any any solution
any solution to let me pick a good
different new color
any solution on our solution set
let me see right there let's say that
that is some arbitrary solution on our
solution set
right that's going to be a point in r2
and any point in r2 can be represented
as a sum of some vector in our row space
and some vector in our null space and so
if i have this vector right here how
could i do that well i could represent
it as a sum of this guy right here
and then
this vector right here
that vector right here and this vector
right here is clearly a member of my
null space i just shifted over this line
is only when i draw in standard position
this
vector right here i'm just showing it
heads to tails if i add this member of
my row space to this member of my null
space i get an arbitrary solution to my
solution set and if you think about it
the projection of my arbitrary solution
onto my row space
will be this guy right here and that
just comes from our uh our well there's
two ways to think about it we could say
that you know let's say that this is a
solution right here we could say our
solution right here is equal to
some member of my row space plus some
member of my null space this is the row
space that is the null space and so by
the definition of a projection onto a
subspace i just gave you we know that
the projection
of this solution onto my let me write a
little bit the projection onto
my row space
onto my row space of my solution is just
equal to this first thing it's equal to
the component of it that's in my row
space it's other component we could call
it is in the orthogonal complement of my
row space or it's in my null space so
this is just going to be equal to the r
vector now i want to show you that that
is essentially that is essentially equal
to the the definition that we did before
that this is completely identical to the
definition of a projection onto a line
because in this case
the subspace is a line so let's find a
pretty let's find a solution set and the
easiest one
the easiest solution that we could find
is if we set c is equal to 0 here we
know that x equals 3 0 is one of the
solutions so x equals 3 0 looks like
that so we know x equals
3 0
is a solution
and what we want to do is we want to
find this shortest solution
or we want to find the projection of x
onto the row space or if we wanted we
could also think of it as a projection
of x onto this line this line is equal
to the row space
so let's do that i'm doing this to show
you that this definition of a projection
onto a subspace
that i've just introduced you to in this
video it is completely identical to the
the definition or it's not identical
it's consistent with the definition of a
projection onto a line although this is
more general because a subspace doesn't
have to be a line but in this case it is
a line so let's do that so the
projection
the projection of 3 0
the projection of the vector 3 0 onto
our row space
which is a line so we can use that
formula it is equal to
3 0
dot the spanning vector for our row
space right not the spanning vector for
our row space that's three minus two we
could have there's a bunch of spanning
vectors for your row space this is just
the one we happen to pick so
dot
three
minus two
all over the spanning vector dotted with
itself three minus two dot three minus
two and then this is just going to be
one big scalar and then we wanna
multiply that
or essentially scale up our actual
spanning vector by that so this is the
projection of this solution
onto my row space which should give me
this vector right here because we're
just taking a projection onto a line
because the row space in this this
subspace is a line and so we use the
linear projections that we were we first
got introduced to i think when i first
started doing linear transformations so
what is three so let's see this is three
times three three times three plus zero
times minus two zero times minus two
this right here is equal to nine this is
three times three
plus
let's see this is three times three plus
minus two times minus two so that's nine
plus four
that's thirteen so it's nine over 13
times this vector right here so we're
going to get it's going to be equal to 9
over 13
times the vector 3 minus 2 which is
equal to the vector 27 over 13
and then minus 18 over 13
which is this vector right here
which is this vector right here which we
we got this exact answer when we first
did it although we just didn't use the
projection onto a line but now we see
that this is exactly consistent with
what we did before we just use the
projection onto a line and we see that
this is consistent with our new broader
definition of a projection
our new broader definition of projection
here we were able to do it because we
did it onto a line but here i'm calling
a projection
i'm calling a projection
any onto any subspace we know how to do
it if it's a line but so far i've just
kind of defined it onto an arbitrary
subspace but i haven't given you a nice
mathematical i guess or computational
way to figure out what this is going to
be if this isn't a line
in fact i haven't even showed you when
this is general whether this is
definitely a linear transformation we
know that when you take the projection
onto a line it's a linear transformation
but i haven't shown you that when we
take a projection onto an arbitrary
subspace that it is a linear projection
i'll do that in the next video